[Music]
hi there and welcome back to the next
live show I'm reto Meier and I'm
Stephanie Wong it's our last day
together here at Google cloud next
nineteen these past two days have been a
whirlwind of product announcements demos
experiments and inspirational stories
from people who are dedicated to making
the clouds better for everyone and to
help with that mission we've made all
that content easily accessible to you at
gos laughs next on air there you'll find
videos of everything with live streams
and recorded it next including the
keynotes all the breakout sessions and
fireside chats and all the next live
show demos special interviews with
Google cloud leaders and more it's all
on demand for you to watch and share you
still have time to check out the other
five channels of next live programming
organized by themes build run analyze
and learn secure and collaborate with
join now by Adam Seligmann vice
president of developer relations now I
love the theme of last night's keynote
get to the fun part can you talk a
little bit about how you chose that
theme and why you feel it resonates
without develop isn't really all
technical practitioners yeah you bet
thanks for having me it's exciting the
exciting to be here keynote was super
fun and the whole idea was to really
celebrate what developers and operators
actually do every day you know hopefully
they're spending hours a day
productively building apps running apps
- playing apps monitoring apps and not
dealing with all the other stuff you
know that you normally have to do when
you build applications especially in the
enterprise you know you know getting out
of waterfall and getting to agile not
just throwing over an app over the wall
for someone else to operate but taking
ownership and a DevOps culture and
operating and really removing all the
barriers everything from you know not
having to manage and shard databases not
have to manually like manage your VMs or
even pick VM sizes and really just you
know get to the heart of building
applications and then let the cloud take
care of it from there that that was the
spirit we wanted to capture in the
keynote so configuring networks
rewriting apps due to cloud provider
changes and waiting around for build
test and deploy are clearly not the fun
parts didn't Google once faced these
sort of issues and how were we able to
remedy that at such scale Google has
been a lot of great software to run
these services that billions of people
use every day so a lot of
a couple of decades of experience when
it how do we help Google developers
become incredibly productive so they can
spend an hour six hours on average of
writing software every day and
absolutely minimize everything else in
the chain of getting to deployment and
getting that service out to production
where a small number of users can test
it is a canary deployment and start
giving you feedback so we're trying to
build that into our cloud we've seen the
rise of DevOps practices up up out in
the industry but now we're building in
newer products with products like cloud
code like manage kubernetes and CSP
cloud run our new serverless offering
just really reducing the barriers that
anyone like a Google engineer can build
code and get it in production as easily
as possible fantastic now if you had to
pick just one just one best practice
from yesterday's keynote that you want
developers to walk away with what would
it be I'm gonna cheat a little and
instead of like I think Google said I
really like what twinkled acai said who
is a VP at Cole's who started her career
as a developer and a UNIX is admin and
she built a lot of automation at calls
now she runs couple years later she has
a 200 person team they have a hundred
micro services 5,000 containers it's all
automated it's running on manage gke on
Prem she said they've been through two
big holiday shopping windows which you
know in retail is a really big deal so
I'm thrilled that Google cloud can
support retail customers but by making
her people super productive it's been
really great for calls and really great
for her career that's an inspirational
customer story we also saw incredible
demos during the keynote yesterday can
you tell us about some of them and which
one was your favorite ah there was a
couple that were a lot of fun I really
like what Wix is doing with Google cloud
you know they've gone from being like a
drag-and-drop web environment but now
it's totally totally programmable and
extensible at Google cloud that's really
exciting the opening demo that that
Mandy Waite led us through like her dev
team is taking us through was very very
cool because it was a mix of developers
doing VM based development with Jenkins
for deployment of new VM images a
container based app in the middle and
then extending with new services with
functions serverless functions which is
pretty cool so to see all those teams
kind of working together and using tools
like cloud code our new IDE integration
for vyas code and IntelliJ just awesome
people can work the way they want to
work it all works together all runs on
Google Cloud seamlessly one pane of
glass with stack driver to observe and
manage it and I think that's great let
developers do what they want and get to
the fun parts
that's fantastic thank you so much again
for joining us today and giving us some
of that great information and let's
check in with Joanna for a closer look
at the network postcard experiment and
to understand why speed matters hi I'm
in a dead zone once again but now I'm
with Terrance Ryan who's one of my
favorite co-workers I'm not gonna lie
about that but so this demo in
particular it's a digital postcard is
that right yeah that's kind of the idea
it is you take a selfie or a picture and
we will bounce it around our network our
private network all around the world and
print it out for you so the pictures
that you get over here our pictures that
have traveled around the world digitally
each data center each data center we
have a stamp for it and it doesn't stamp
it until it's in that dataset now when
you talk about a private network you
mean the actual physical cables and data
centers that Google built around the
world right yeah exactly the same data
centers and same infrastructure that
powers search and mail also under the
covers it's available Google Cloud
customers as their private network so
whenever you talk between one machine
and another machine of Google Cloud
that's always traveling on our network
it never leaves the network and so you
get much better performance in terms of
being able to communicate and security
because it's not leaving it's not on the
public Internet oh my gosh this is
actually where my favorite facts about
Google Cloud it's a fun fact which is we
built an infrastructure to power our
search and then we started opening that
up to other people so that you don't
have to reinvent the wheel but it's
really important that I make it easy to
use was this pretty easy to set up
absolutely like one of the great things
about Google clouds default networking
in our project is if all the machines
are in the same project all the VM and
VMs are order powering the relaying and
the stand
if they're all in the same project then
they are automatically wired to talk to
one another without the developer having
to do any work to make that happen
and so what that allows you to do is
kind of get started without you know
having to set up like VPNs and be pcs to
get all that working all of that is done
for you all the routing is done for you
and if you want this is an open-source
project so you can actually pull down
and see how we set it up and see that
like it really is that super simple and
I like that it makes it accessible to
someone who might not have that
networking experience or background but
so long as they can understand the
theory they can actually get going yep
exactly this is so exciting I love this
demo I am so happy to take home my
photos and more importantly the fact
that it is open source means that anyone
at home can play along even if you don't
get to have your own cute photo to take
home and I hope you'll have a great time
and thanks for joining me in the dead
zone
great job team the next session is about
to begin so we'll see you right back
here in less than an hour for a deep
dive discussion on api's with Amit
savory VP of engineering at Apogee then
we'll head back to our showcase for more
demos stick around you're watching the
next live show from San Francisco
[Music]
I'm reto Meier and I'm Stephanie Wong
here with AMA it's a very VP of
engineering to dive into api's welcome
and thanks for joining us thanks for
having me so I want to talk about api's
which have come a long way from the
software interfaces popularized by win32
API so tell us where they are today and
your predictions for API is in 2019 and
where ap Apogee lies in this space
sure sure I think we look at what's
going on in the industry today there
many things which are driving the
modernization of a lot of existing
applications right so if the eyes are
becoming the front end to a lot of the
assets companies have already in their
portfolio and the unlock lot of those
content for different kind of users be
it end-users beat partners as well as
employees so I think if you look at
going forward in 2019 you start seeing a
lot of different ways of exposing those
api's one the lot of companies are using
trying to monetize on them to be able to
kind of use that to create a lot of new
content as well as partnerships so we a
lot of good examples of customers like
say magazine Luiza in Brazil who is
trying to create a lot of e-commerce
kind of content and be able to expose a
lot of data to the end-user to buy it
same thing with AccuWeather where they
want to be able to now take a lot of the
weather data and share it and bring it
make it available to a lot of other end
users as well so that's one kind of
driving factor second thing is
popularization of a lot of ways of
interfacing through voice and text so
you see BOTS
you see of course a different kind of
consumer devices and that requires a lot
of interfaces into the backend systems
and be able to expose it through voice
in text so that's also driving a lot of
interest from companies to be able to
use API management for that and third
area we seen a lot of kind of driving
factor and you'll see a lot of it as we
move forward it's a lot of Industry
requirements all right so there's a lot
of open standards coming out a lot of
regulations coming out and API is the
one way to kind
log the content and make sure they're
secured and they are available to the
right people so that's another complete
new requirement to be seeing and
becoming very popular as we move forward
that's exciting
now obviously a lot of API is that drive
ecosystems are publicly visible but many
of the API is at any given company are
only used internally how does effigy
support both of those use cases sure so
I think the way we have build a platform
at in the Apogee area was to really make
sure that anybody who wants to expose
API we provide them ways to kind of
manage the whole process beat internal
external users and so the platform is
really kind of agnostic of that fact but
we of course do provide a lot of
safeguarding when it's externally
exposed a lot of the right kind of
regulations the right kind of
permissions security elements are built
in similarly inside when you try to
expose it inside then Enterprise anybody
don't use it between different employees
for different application development
again we provide the whole lifecycle
management for it so there are a lot of
again capabilities for a developer to
use and leverage when they're building
those applications and they can decide
the rules and how and what the to be
shared and the lor features kind of
build in to really make that happen and
a lot of companies are now looking
towards micro services but micro
services will continue have a lot of
different recipes successful micro
service architecture is complex to
design build and manage and there are a
lot of experimentation going on but the
key is to build reusable decoupled
services I can scale with the right
levels of governance
how is Apogee helping to support micro
service architecture I think general if
you look at the architecture evolution
in general is ideas we really have a
small small kind of services and kind of
decoupled in a way right and then the
best way to kind of use those services
is through an API so what what Apogee
does is now that we have interface is to
kind of a lot of the micro services
management layer and for example is
steel which Google provides as a service
allows you to now expose those micro
services manage them in a much better
way and orchestrate and kind of we do a
lot of monitoring around it and what we
do with Apogee is integrate with steel
and really provide the ability to manage
those API is through one of those
channel one in one way otherwise if you
have other micro services you have an
API we can of course manage that
lifecycle for that and allow you to use
in a much better fashion than the
marketing application would be yes can
you talk a little bit about the new
general availability release of Apogee
edge for private club
yeah I think the way the baby looking at
Apogee in general is to have a
deployment model which is flexible right
so one is to be able to of course you
can continue using it on Prem second
thing is to be able to now take it in
the cloud we have an Apogee edge
products available in the cloud as well
fully managed by Google third is this
hybrid mechanism where you can have some
of the runtime running anywhere you
choose be the private cloud or
on-premise you can be running on
kubernetes or gke and they'll run and
the control plane is running in the
cloud and could that could be in any any
cloud could be a Google or any third
party cloud as well so we try to make
sure the architecture is very flexible
giving choices to the customers and
developers to really deploy the way they
would want to and specifically with edge
we do provide a private cloud edition
where you can run on gke and gke
on-premise can be available anywhere a
developer want to choose to deploy it
and we allow you to kind of have it very
easy and easy to manage and easy to
deploy so that's available today and we
continue to kind of make progress in
that area setting so we know that API is
and building API isn't just enough you
have to actually convince your
developers to use them and that means
developer portals become key how does a
pichu's developer portal and its
enhancements help that happen yeah I
think to tie everything together you
have to have them have a structure where
this information can be available right
so the developers of course would love
to have one way of in terms of how you
manage those APRs but how do you expose
it is to a developer portal so Appaji
provides a lot of capabilities on the
developer portal side so we have a
customer facing portal a partner facing
portal all the lifecycle for kind of
getting api's into the portal as well
all the services are available so
developer doesn't have to do a lot of
the heavy lifting in terms of how to
share that content how kind of get right
kind of security around it so the
developer portal today is available
through all of our other products and we
keep on making enhancements to it
there's one offering through Drupal as
well to a third-party CMS if a customer
chooses to use a heavy duty
portal and has a lot more capabilities
for a lot of specific things custom work
you might want to do but we also have an
integrated portal it's part of our
offering today which is very simple easy
to you
you can create a lot of interface into
Portal interfaces for end users very
quickly and easily that's great a
purchase belts on best practice to help
create world-class developer experiences
right so tell me a little bit about a
little bit more about that I think in
general I think just not Apogee if you
look at Google we've been trying to make
sure the Google cloud make developer
experience very friendly right and I
think one of the key things for
developer is a lifecycle of how do you
create an application and for that at
the one big part of that is the API
management for it in terms of the whole
lifecycle so we have made sure if a
developer it's very easy to onboard they
can start writing an API and they can
start kind of documenting it testing it
and and design and delivering it so we
provide a lot of tooling for that very
simple easy to use and what we've been
doing beyond that it's really how now
kind of giving you metering monitoring
monetization so now we have an idea
who's using what what kind of security
you have what kind of privileges were
provided to that user as well as what
kind of users you got out of it and how
much money you can make out of it so you
have a lot of the data availability idea
fingertips so we've been doing a lot of
work to really add a lot of this value
add the unjust being able to build an
API and deliver it but also all the
things you need it on monitoring
metering security monetization so that's
really becoming very powerful element
into the feature capabilities for
developers and anybody else who want to
do this work thank you so much omote we
packed a lot of info into our talk so
thanks for your time thanks for having
me if you've got a question or comment
on api's be sure to reach out to us on
social media with the hashtag Google
next nineteen now let's head back to our
showcase for a look at more demos
we're here in the customer magic
neighborhood with kind of a pretty
impressive booth here with NASA and
James the director of NASA FDA yeah I am
I'm the Nasir FTL is an applied AI
research lab for NASA
it's a public-private partnership which
is great so it means we can ask
corporate partners of experts and they
either help us with our problems
so with that in mind yeah how does
Google Cloud and NASA FTL work together
well we had a big problem and the
problem was are we alone which is kind
of the big one and we knew that you like
big problems so we thought well hey
Google and see if they can help us
what's interesting about this problem is
we have scientists who are fantastic at
understanding the problem and enormous
data like data you can't imagine how big
it is huge and and so really we needed a
corporate expert like I like doing the
helped us what we prototypes was Google
power with FTL is the sort of
relationships and sort of partnerships
which NASA is going to need if we're
going to be putting in people on the
moon in five years so it's really if you
like we kind of turn the water about how
the future should be just in terms of
you know the way we're solving problems
the way we're partnering you know that's
that's what we're weaving prototyping
with you guys that's really you know
what Google's to me
and I have to say thank you for the help
you guys have given because we did it
we've done some really extraordinary
work here and I think NASA's gonna take
us through some of the some of the
fragments of what was done and this is
what you can come and see at this this
booth we're very proud of the work and
they'd just like to say thanks again of
course I mean it's great to hear it's
super exciting to see this kind of
really turn to what can we actually do
with this technology how do we help
people and so we're gonna walk through
and see what people hear it next can
kind of get their hands on and
experiment with and then also see how
does that help us answer are we alone
yeah the team we've done a great job of
taking something really complex and
making really simple and you can have a
go and you know play with like curbs and
find the exoplanets so there's some
really cool stuff to to get your hands
on here as well awesome
let's take a look yeah so we just talked
to James about how the partnership
between NASA FTL and Google cloud helped
the naval scientists to really start
doing this analysis what can people here
at next actually play with to see what
that looks like
absolutely so the the challenge was
Grundy right finding life on other
planets so how do you break it down in
steps so step one you have to find other
planets that are outside the solar
system right so we actually worked on
that challenge to start with and what
you can see here is a little bit of a
representation of how that works so the
way we have one of these light curves
and the task here you can do is actually
try to kind of classify by eyes this a
planet or not so as you can see actually
it's a quite hard task you know like you
have to kind of understand when things
our planet or not and there are a lot of
like subtleties here this takes actually
a lot of human labor and a lot of like
astrophysics mine's actually spent on
this for years so what we had as an idea
is that can actually have machine
learning help us with this and so we use
actually the power of like deep learning
and AI in Google cloud to kind of train
a model that does this so the
researchers did this actually with our
technology and actually they were able
to get a model that is not only more
accurate than humans it can actually
kind of process entire data set see
minutes where before she took here's so
people can kind of see the details of
why it was so important to have machine
learning help out the human
that was required to make this happen
absolutely so for those exoplanets can
we take a look at those in the mobile
apps over there yeah so like here we
have a very simple app that you can use
to kind of scan the sky and there are a
lot of like planets in the sky and once
you point at one of those planets you
can actually kind of study it and you
would get the composition of the
atmosphere of that planet so this
actually is more kind of a gamified
version of this that represents why is
this so important so this is like a cool
way to see and kind of get a little bit
of a taste into exactly what goes into
making those decisions and understanding
all the technology that's required to
say look we're now making these
predictions let's see if we can find
somewhere and actually answer is there
life out there absolutely and again I
mean like the the beauty of this is that
a lot of this work has been done by
astrophysicists and you know kind of
astronomy researchers that didn't have a
lot of like IT knowledge or AI knowledge
they were just like powered by both the
power of computation in Google cloud and
by our AI tools kind of answered this
really really hard questions right it
lets them focus on what's important to
them and the technology just helps
enable it absolutely that's awesome
thanks so much thank you
[Music]
hi everyone my name's Natalie and we are
here in the G suite demo booth and I'm
joined here by Ricard who is from Gant a
customer who had an amazing digital
transformation with G Suites welcome
thank you thank you very much tell us a
little bit about Gant and how you opened
up a new store with G suite in three
months amazing for Gant is a fashion
brand
we're headquarters in Stockholm today
we're an old company was actually born
in USA from the beginning one of the
things that we did is we brought the
button-down shirt to the market so a
couple of years ago we had a challenge
where we had to open up a new street a
new store on Regent Street in London and
we had a record amount we have to do it
in a record amount of time so we usually
what usually takes one year we had to do
in three months we have to work fast so
we've actually got Whitney here as well
who's going to take us through demo is
that right here we have a cool video of
the London store actually being built
out by the team and as they were
planning they had a lot of documents
going around they needed to be able to
get everyone on the same page working on
the same document moving quickly
together and so they used to send file
versions back and forth all the time and
they really really slowed down the
process so they switched to Google Docs
and using Google Docs they were all able
to work together on the same document in
all all the different teams across their
locations and they were able to comment
each other in to assign tasks get inputs
from team members across all different
locations and able to just really move
quickly together because they were all
running in that same document we're
gonna move now from our London store
team to the Stockholm headquarters team
okay so now you're going to show us what
the Stockholm team was doing the
inventory planning right
yes exactly so we've just moved into the
Stockholm headquarters where the team
was also working really hard to prepare
for the London store opening and they
were focused mostly on planning all of
the inventory that was going to be
needed for the new store and so in order
to do that they needed everyone working
on the same spreadsheet planning what
was going on planning where the clothes
were coming from how much we needed of
each item things like that and the same
way with Doc said they were all able to
collaborate live on that one document
they were able to do the same thing on
the spreadsheet which helped them move
really quickly as well
and they also used a feature called
sheets Explorer which allows people to
ask questions about their data in
natural language so they can get
insights from their data like what's the
average price for quantity and things
like that and that way they're able to
get all the information they need to
plan really effectively but it's you're
actually asking through voice those
types of questions it's it's awesome
because a lot of people kind of
businesses don't necessarily know how to
write C cool or complex queries the
sheet explorer toy is amazing for them
yeah no longer do we have the headaches
of creating all the pivot tables yeah
and writing you can just go in and get
those insights from your data right away
great ok now we're going to imagine
we're in another country right we've
made it to Portugal where the Gantt
manufacturing facility is located Kwik
Trip and so the team here was working
really hard to create all of the
clothing that was going to be needed for
the store and so they were hard at work
in the manufacturing facility really to
make the best items they could but they
needed to get approvals from the London
and the Stockholm teams who were doing
the designs and wanted to make sure it
was the quality they were looking for
and things like that and sometimes those
decisions just need to be made face to
face yeah exactly and so the gap team
used to fly people to the manufacturing
facilities to check out the clothing
make sure it all looked good but now
they've really switched to you
ding meet which is G Suites video
conferencing solution and using meet
they're able to get everyone in the same
room virtually so they can still see the
look and the feel of the clothing and so
now I'm actually gonna have the
opportunity to show you how they would
do that so we're already hooked into
this meeting on our computer and I'm
going to show you how the team in the
manufacturing facility is able to join
with one click from the phone and then
they actually will walk around with the
phone and join the meeting and be able
to see the clothing get a feel for it
and this way get all of the approvals
they need for the clothing amazing so
it's you know you get the feeling that
you're actually in Porto although your
instructor more London that's amazing
well thank you so much for this walk
around this has definitely been one of
the most interactive sessions and
demonstrations thanks Whitney
and our Ricard also I guess you know the
G suite technology is amazing but I I'm
assuming this just meant so much for
your customers to be able to move from
producing a store in one year to three
months it did it was a wreckin time and
we ended up with happy customers
definitely I'd imagine you did thank you
so much both for joining us thanks and
back to you alright thanks team coming
up after this next round of sessions a
Lunch and Learn on building amazing apps
with cloud fire store we'll have a live
demo on service monitoring with
stackdriver
stay tuned we'll see you in about an
hour you're watching the next live show
from San Francisco
[Music]
welcome back to the next live show
building the club for everyone takes
everyone to create and embrace a culture
that is inclusive and representative of
our communities here at next nineteen in
San Francisco diversity equality and
inclusion is part of our DNA
recently Forbes magazine recognized
their commitment naming next as one of
the top three conferences for women to
thrive let's check in with Joanna for
more on the inclusion lounge and the
hash tag I am remarkable workshops
happening here at next thanks so much
Stephanie I'm so excited to be here at
our inclusion lounge because diversity
is something that I obviously care a lot
about but more important than just being
diverse is making sure that we have
multiple perspectives at the table so
that we can build really interesting
solutions to fun problems so now we're
talking to tailor who drives diversity
equity and inclusion that next hi thank
you this lounge is great you want to
tell me some fun facts about it
welcome to the inclusion lounge and you
know the purpose of the inclusion lounge
is to make sure that at necks were
always providing content and experiences
to support underrepresented groups and a
life to be able to come together share
learnings collaborate and build
communities so yeah it's a it's a safe
space and it
anytime people could drop by connect
with like-minded others get confidence
coaching and also get head shots and
then in the interim we also have
sessions like I'm remarkable which is
going on right around our shoulder yeah
and this session is happening a couple
times at max and it takes us through an
exercise of empowerment and learning how
to promote ourselves in all the positive
ways what do you think really makes the
inclusion law to stand out and why
should people think about coming here
during their day yeah you know it it's
not even about thinking about it it's
just knowing that it's available because
so much about inclusion is you have to
be ready to be in the space yes and when
you're ready to receive and you're ready
to learn from others and become an ally
or become an advocate that's the time to
actually visit and it should be in an
intimidating space it should be a space
where you could feel like you could be
welcomed
you can meet like-minded people and you
can actually learn and listen from one
another our attendees are always sharing
with us that whether they're an
introvert or an extrovert they need a
place to unwind and step away from the
commotion of next and all the wonderful
experiences that are available here and
then they're really able to then go from
a collaborative mindset rather than an
overwhelmed by sense thank you again for
building this space
I really admire it thanks for coming to
talk to us about it and all we feel that
you could drop by at the inclusion
lounge because we all know it's really
important next to build a cloud for
everyone thanks everyone
thanks very much Joanna I'm excited to
have Priyanka Vergara a customer
engineer at Google cloud here with me to
show us how to set up service level
monitoring and stackdriver hi franca hi
Stephanie thank you for having me thank
you
google has published our practices for
managing reliable services at scale and
site reliability engineering books and
this sre workbook one of the main
principles of sre is using service level
objectives can you show us how
developers can do the same yeah let's
dive right in and let me show it through
a demo great perfect so I have this
website here that is built to order some
stuff and so I'm going to put something
in the cart and it's it's an e-commerce
website
you order things and then it places an
order so I have my credit-card
information in there and we just placed
an order now behind the scenes there's a
lot going on in this particular
application so if we look at what's
going on here this is the service
architecture of the application and it
is talking it has a front end it has
various different services talking to
the front end checkout the catalog the
product catalog the card service this is
a lot that's going on here
and if you see further they're pretty
much all written in very different
languages as well so there's a lot of
complexity behind the scenes that's
that's going on and this is all done
through micro services as he as you can
see so it's it's important to understand
that a simple website is set up with
with different that can be set up with
different services in the backend and
have different languages that it can be
written in so complexities right and
micro servers architectures mean the app
itself is broken into many small pieces
and doesn't that make it hard to
understand how all the pieces fit
together and where to start
investigating when there is a problem
it's very it becomes very hard for the
operations team especially in micro
services architecture to figure out
what's going on which services is up
down talking to each other so it there's
a good tool in stackdriver monitoring
called topology where you can actually
look at the topology of your different
micro services talking to each other so
I have it open here and when you open
the service topology I can look at a
specific service that I'm interested in
and then see which other services it is
talking to so it gives me a view I can
click on one and it gives me a view of
what's going on and which services it is
talking to you which is pretty helpful
when you're working in an environment
that has so many different services
micro services that it's talking to well
and this is great because with micro
service based apps you can clearly see
the inter-service dependencies and use
that to double check new code rollouts
but let's say you're setting up alerts
ops staff can burn out a lot of the
times from getting notified of all the
potential causes of a problem making it
hard to online sres with customer
interests how can we identify which
behaviors really actually matter for
service during service degradation yeah
so there is also another tool within
stat driver monitoring for services
where you can actually set up SL o--'s
and define which define your s allows
for the services so operations does not
actually get affected by just looking at
all the different alerts that that can
come by it's actually a practice within
our sre teams where we make sure that
our there are a sorry staff is only
monitoring alerts that are related to
customer issues and and front-end
customer related issues and not every
single issue that might be it might be a
cause to those issues so let's let's see
that in a in the demo as well yeah so if
we click on services here in the strap
driver monitoring let's look at
front-end and when we go do that you're
able to see the service level
optimization so let me click on SL OHS
and in SLO so you obviously see nothing
here so we're going to set one up and
say we want to set up for availability
and then there is we can do a rolling or
calendar I want to say in the month if
we reach 99% or no availability then I
want to get alerted that is that's a
good way of saying that you're not gonna
be alerted for everything but you still
want to be alerted for when we go less
than 99 percent and then you can also
set up a latency alert so in this case
if we say latency and I want to set up
differently for different services for
the front-end you could say my pager
should load in less than thousand
milliseconds otherwise I want to be
notified and in this case also let's say
it's 90% our goal and then we submit
that so these are the two alerts that we
just set up for latency and availability
and they are not just thresholds because
we are saying this percentile so it's
not going to be chatty and noisy it's
going to be if this happens then we
really want to get notified because the
service is not working fine so that's
that's a good way of identifying
making sure that you're not burning out
your your operations to excellent how do
you follow these best practices given
the resources that you have yeah so you
also have metrics and diagnostics in
there so if you click on metrics you're
able to see the request counts and the
response latency is which which will
guide you through the request and
response and if you click on Diagnostics
that actually takes you to the trace so
now if I want to drill deeper into the
95th percentile which is probably the
one I want to look at because it's not
performing very well then I can click on
that and see a specific request why it
was slow for for what reasons and which
requests were actually so so in this
case we can see that the checkout
service was a little bit slow in send
and receive so we may want to do deeper
into that and find out what's going on
there so the Diagnostics tab and the
metrics tab are really good friends for
troubleshooting great and at some point
you probably need to dig a little deeper
into the services signals let's say
maybe you received an SLO earlier and
there's no obvious upstream cause or you
have a customer complaint outside of an
SLO alert that you need to investigate
or maybe you need to see how the new
rollout of your code version is going
how do you get a coherent display of all
the signals for a specific service yeah
so I think the best the best thing to do
at that point is you you got an alert
through SLO you want to look at metrics
and Diagnostics to kind of figure out
what's going on because metrics and
Diagnostics are going to be helpful to
understand which specific service is not
performing well as you can see in
Diagnostics when we drill deeper into a
specific service we were able to find
out that check out is the culprit and so
we can drill deeper into that so those
metrics and Diagnostics would be your
great friends in order to find out
what's actually going on so stackdriver
service monitoring gives you a whole new
way to view your application
architecture reason about its customer
facing behaviors and get to the root of
any problem that arises so thank you so
much for Yonder for showing us how
Google is transforming the ops
experience of cloud native and micro
service deployments thank you for having
me it was fun time now for our next step
fight if you want to learn how to build
amazing apps with cloud firestore check
this out let's say you want to build an
app not just any app but a server less
scalable mobile sync
analytical IOT app if you do a quick
Google search you will get one point two
billion results on how to do this so
where do you start my name is nathalie
vase and I'm a product manager on cloud
firestore today I want to talk to you
about building amazing apps specifically
how to build globally scalable apps with
cloud fired store if you're starting a
new project from scratch and you want to
build it yourself you'll likely have to
think about a couple of things number
one setting up a database number two
creating some kind of API layer on top
of it so you can make queries from your
clients and that probably means third
creating an authentication service to
make sure users can only access data
they're supposed to and then lastly
making sure your data syncs with your
local results which are probably being
stored in a completely separate client
database now just make sure it works
across multiple platforms it can easily
handle things like spotty network
connections simple right
as soon as your app goes viral fingers
crossed for you all of a sudden you have
to worry about scaling high availability
and disaster recovery strategies and
you'll probably need to hire more people
to manage it too or you can just use
cloud fire store
cloud fire store is a fully managed
server 'less no sequel document database
purpose-built for solving some of the
toughest problems of mobile web and IOT
app development today in many ways it's
more than a database it's an entire
back-end for your apps to create fire
store we learned from two other popular
databases at Google
firebase real time database and cloud
datastore usage patterns have shifted
since those architectures were designed
some seven to ten years ago respectively
so we took a close look at the developer
wish list for each of these to inform
the product you can think of fire store
as the best of both of these worlds
cloud fire store handles all the things
that you don't want to think about when
you're developing a mobile app so you
can really focus on your core business
the first thing to know is that cloud
fire store is fully supported in the
firebase SDKs this includes web iOS and
Android so you can access data directly
from these clients
this works in conjunction with firebase
auth and security rules and those things
allow you to control who has access to
read and modify data on the server
there's that off layer we mentioned at
the beginning you wouldn't believe how
normal it has become for people to look
at their apps when there is absolutely
no chance of connectivity a person
checks their phone an average of 80
times in a day so it's becoming
increasingly common for people to expect
our apps to work offline and across
devices with cloud firestore the client
libraries already come with full support
for offline mode the sdk handles
conflict resolution on device and syncs
up with the server when you reconnect
because we built cloud firestore with
the serverless architecture you don't
have to worry about provisioning
capacity planning scaling or maintenance
there are servers distributed across the
world just not ones that you have to
manage all of this is taken care of by
the system scaling is automatic and
happens as an online operation say
goodbye to maintenance windows on top of
that cloud fire store is built for the
cloud that means it's replicated across
zones and regions depending on how you
choose to configure it and this year
alone and as part of going generally
available we added 10 new locations to
cloud fire store replication across data
centers is really one of those things
you want to outsource if you can it
becomes complicated quickly and is a
huge overhead for ops teams with this
replication you get five nines SLA for
multi region and a four nines SLA for
regional deployments this is one of the
highest availability services we offer
all of this lets you focus on your core
business and leave the infrastructure to
Google Cloud which is our core business
with over 1 million databases created
already cloud firestore has seen a huge
diversity of workloads are you deployed
within our customer base the unifying
themes among these workloads include
number one the need for data access even
when connectivity lapses number two
scalability for many users across
platforms and number 3 the ability to
move quick
from prototype to production and that's
cloud firestore your Auto synching
auto-scaling database in the cloud give
it a try and find out why it's the most
discussed cloud database on stack
overflow
[Music]
thanks so much team stay right here for
more sessions on all six live stream
channels after the sessions join us for
a chat with security product manager ray
Wang about building secure environments
with Google cloud this is the next live
show coming to you from the heart of San
Francisco
[Music]
welcome back to the next live show I'm
reto Meier and I'm Stephanie watts
joining us now ray Wang security product
manager for Google cloud thanks so much
for joining us thank you it's great to
be here so security is such a vital part
of everything we do online and in the
cloud let's talk about security at scale
as our environments grow larger security
simply must keep up
how is network security changing as we
move from brittle environments built on
static IPS to micro services yeah the
traditional IP based networking policies
require to have very detailed knowledge
on the nitty gritty you can parts of
your security networking configurations
they don't really offer your concept of
which service can talk to what unless
you know you segregate them by IP
addresses and subnets ahead of time and
this quickly becomes unwieldy right as
you scale your infrastructure especially
as you introduce the concept of micro
services and this is where a cloud
native platform like a steel or dementia
version CSM give you a very different
kind of experience they allow the admins
to define high-level policies that focus
on application requirements our business
logic the micro services are backed by
namespaces which give you natural
isolation boundaries and each services
is also given a unique SEO service
identity then you can set policies
leveraging these identities and
boundaries for example you can set it to
be zero trust by default between
services so that any communication will
require explicit policies and then Metro
TRS is enforced by default and once you
have configured a policies CSM can allow
you to centrally manage and monitor and
control service to service traffic and
alert on any policy violation so this is
how you know where the micro service
focused a platform acts ESM it's much
simpler to to both create and do ongoing
monitoring of your network security
policies
so how does moving into a hybrid cloud
environment impact security yeah so
moving to hybrid environment especially
with radical Enzo's right means no you
now have a consistent control playing
between on-prem and cloud it gives you a
single admin experience in a single pane
of glass which makes a much simpler to
have central visibility and control
across a hybrid deployments and then you
can also start using some of the Google
security capabilities even for young
prime workloads for example products
like binary authorization or and those
config management now work for on Prem
as well and of course another benefit of
using hybrid platform is that helps your
work clothes to get clout ready
right because containers are a portable
and yamming spirits the same so when it
comes to time to migrate it's a very
straightforward process and of course
once your workloads migrated to cloud we
offer you additional security values
things like shield at the end or zero
downtime patching through live migration
even when there are really big you know
Hardware round or abilities like specter
and meltdown you mentioned security
consistency what are some of the best
practices to ensure a security baseline
with consistency and reproducibility for
all of your resources in the cloud great
question we know that security is kind
of shared responsibility right we do our
part and customers do their parts so in
a platform we offer a lot of security
capability so that customers can start
on a much higher baseline by the same
time we also make sure that you also
want to make sure your your part of
responsibility becomes easy as well and
that's often down through you know
templatized departments central config
and policy management and ongoing
monitoring and learning so then in terms
of deployments by using kubernetes style
api you can express your configurations
as decorator templates then
entos config management gave you a
central source of truth for these
templates and allow you to deploy the
config and policy updates by get-ups and
crc deepest patches these changes then
get deploy to across all of your
clusters and measures in environment
to ensure consistency and when it comes
to constraints the cup of frameworks
they keep her policy controller and
facility config validators that we are
actually developing any open source with
with communities they allow admins to
standardize configurations across your
entire organization you can for example
set guardrails buy presubmit checks in
your release pipeline so that miss
configuration can't even get into the
deployment process and then in case you
know drift happened in production you
can also set alerts so they in general
is notified for monitoring we also have
cloud asset inventory and cloud security
command center they give you a central
view of the state of all of your
resources in production and then cannot
value of changes and risks and security
findings are so out so together these
tools help you through the lifecycle of
managing your security config settings
it's fantastic can you talk a little bit
about declarative configs to make
security controls consistent across yeah
so we all know one of the most costly
mistakes and admin can make is this
configuration right it's almost far too
easy to accidentally set your I am
controls to be to be public or you know
make your network configuration to be
too way too permissive and when you do
that you open up your sensitive resource
to two attacks and data leaks so this is
where you know the clergy config makes a
difference because it helps the admin to
focus on the end of the end state and
then allow you to offload the
intermediate orchestration and workflows
and keeping up consistencies really to
the platform and then when we do that
across a lot of resources across many
clusters and meshes we basically achieve
reproducibility and recovery from drift
and and therefore they reduce the
complexity of applying security controls
and they also make it much easier to
share
security best practices because you
can't you can deploy template high
solutions not only is it important to
declare your security configs across
your environment but also monitor and
then
so we have a big launch as you mentioned
cloud security command center how do we
help customers get visibility into risk
in their environments yeah we're very
excited about cloud security command
center because it kind of unifies the
security detections from Google right
together with a lot of the key
third-party detections for the main
essential place and really help the
admins to to build them analyze them and
take actions in place for example when
after capabilities is secured security
health analytics right it skins and
detects over 20 common vulnerabilities
from publicly exposed storage buckets -
we talk about you know overly permissive
firewall rules
- misconfigured kubernetes clusters and
so on and similarly you have cloud
nominee detection it automatically
detects some of the key threats from you
know crypto jackin to expose service
account credentials to outbound DDoS and
then with this GA release another
benefit you get is now cloud SCC unifies
security findings from a variety of
Google cloud products from events rate
detection to binary authorization to
cloud asset inventory - XT + and so on
how you can use it well if you're in a
pressed company right and you have a
finance department for example that
stores credit card information and says
your personal data you can use cloud SCC
to scan the infrastructure used for
storing these system information
identifying vulnerabilities as well as
finding active threats that are
targeting these vulnerabilities and
that's a lot of funding so we give you a
way to manage and organize these
findings by attaching
business context to the findings and the
resources by accurate security marks and
then we all know that getting the data
is the first step right what you really
want to do is to improve your security
post referral data so cloud SCC also
allows you to actually respond to take
actions by for example triggering alerts
or creating IRM incidents or directly
executing in remediation operations by
Club functions great thanks ray your
insights into security will continue to
be vital to any company that wants to
build and grow quickly thank you right
now over the last three days we've
brought you amazing demos from our
showcase but guess what there is so much
here in Nathalie and Mark to take us on
a tour
welcome to the Google cloud next 2019
showcase floor we're super excited to
take you around all the different demo
areas and neighborhoods that we have
around the floor there's lots of cool
stuff down there so why don't we show
you around
[Music]
there's so much great stuff here at
Google cloud next 2019 we've only begun
to scratch the surface with the showcase
as we've shown you and there's tons of
people here with high energy I know
right I think is roughly around thirty
thousand people or more here actually
lots of amazing demo stations where you
can learn about our Google cloud
platform yeah it's super cool but if you
weren't able to see it for yourself
don't forget to check out all the
content on YouTube so you can see us
showcase some of these demos but also
see some great talks that's right and
we're looking forward to seeing you next
time thanks very much Natalie in mock
for those highlights now we want to
share a fun competition that happened
here next earlier this week in on tips
on theater we got to see how heroes are
made in the cloud cloud hero is a
hackathon where players test their
knowledge of Google cloud through time
challenges the challenge is built on an
entirely serverless system using angular
thought firestorm and cloud functions
thank you to all our participants both
here at next as well as online alright
it's time to step away for the next
session and afterwards Stephanie and I
will be back to wrap things up here for
next my team
[Music]
well it's a wrap on behalf of the next
live show crew thank you for hanging out
with us the last three days we had a
great time showing the Google cloud max
19 experience with you but it doesn't
end here everything with live streams
the keynotes the recaps the next live
show experience and all the sessions at
next will be available to watch share
and re-watch on our video on demand page
at gioco slash next on-air next 19 is
about to go global as it heads to Tokyo
and then London later this year follow
us at GTO slash cloud next to stay in
the know so long from San Francisco
thank you so much for watching and we'll
see you next year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you